good morning everybody it is 8:00 a.m.
and after killing my diet with froo
while I was hammered last night at 2:
a.m. I feel like both physically
and mentally yet again with that in mind
there seems like no better time to talk
about systems design and computer
architecture and so as a result I will
be talking about Apache Flink a stream
processing framework I wish there were
someone out there to process my stream
but I don't think it's going to be that
way so let's get into it okay so Flink
what is it well basically Flink is known
as a stream processing framework so up
until this point just because I hadn't
really done my research on this topic I
kind of assumed that Flink itself was
like a message broker and that somehow
it was you know kind of enhancing that
experience but as it turns out Flink is
not a message broker but rather a
software that you run on a cluster of
nodes in order to provide stateful
computations on your actual stream
processing unlike something like spark
uh spark streaming it is giving you the
ability to process these messages in
real time as opposed to just using micr
batching which lets a bunch of these
messages accumulate over you know a
short period of time and then processes
them together um like I mentioned kind
of the whole reason that you would use
something like Flink as opposed to just
using a typical consumer is the fact
that in many stream processing
applications you have to maintain some
sort of State this is in order to
perform things like joins or
aggregations and we'll go ahead and see
some other examples in the coming slides
so so just to quickly visualize the use
case of what you might be using Flink
for as you can see you can kind of
ingest events from either something like
a message broker or maybe even change
data from a database like a file system
or a key value store then as you can see
here in the middle we have these few
different um clusters each running flank
where all of those clusters are um
allowing you to kind of go ahead and
parallelize the computation of actually
um processing each message and each of
them has its own little like key value
store on the Node that it uses in order
to keep track of the messages it's seen
in order to kind of better provide more
functionality then from actually going
ahead and processing these messages you
can then send the messages to a sync
which is basically just the outgoing
place where messages are going to be
sent which can either be um to an
application the application can
obviously be some sort of consumer or it
can be um to uh another stream so
another event log or to another database
okay so let's talk about State and
stream processing cuz I mentioned this
is kind of the bread and butter Flink
and the reason why it's important so why
do we need to actually keep State well
for starters a big point of um stream
processing is to be able to group events
by time so while Flink does let you have
a bunch of kind of flexibility in terms
of which time you're actually going to
use for a given event so that includes
um the actual time it gets to uh the
node that it's going to be processed on
the time that it is received by the
consumer of the stream the the time that
it was actually sent to the log broker
so you have all these options basically
for how to group events but the point is
in order to group events by time
generally speaking you want to be going
ahead and window certain events and that
way messages um from similar time
periods will be sent to the same
partitions to be processed together and
you kind of need some sort of local
state in order to do that additionally
another common case that we see is
something known as stream enrichment
where you're basically taking a bunch of
stream messages and adding some
corresponding information from an
existing database table in order to go
ahead and provide more information for
those messages so for example you know
imagine we had a bunch of web browser
activity coming in and we wanted to go
ahead and use that user ID coming in
with the web browser activity to go
ahead and list some demographics about
the user before we send that to a
secondary stream um you can actually
keep this table local to Flink and then
update it over time using the change
data capture from that table um another
case and this is one that I saw in uh
just one of the videos that I watched
for learning about this topic was just
like a Tinder use case so imagine as
opposed to just storing every single
like or dislike in a database what we
actually did is place every single like
in a stream for asynchronous processing
because we don't have to return a result
instantly so every single like basically
goes into a stream and then we use a
partitioning schema such that all
messages or rather all likes um
consisting of the same two users are
certain to go to the same node in that
Flint cluster and as a result of that if
Flint uh processes a like message and we
see that um the corresponding like from
you know the other user to uh the first
user is already there then we know we
have a match otherwise we don't have a
match we have to store that like and
then hope that um the secondary like
comes in if it doesn't we'll probably
end up expiring those messages after a
certain time period who knows maybe a
week maybe a month or something like
that okay let's talk about fault
tolerance because obviously if you're
storing any state in either memory or
disk and it's just going to be local to
one node we run the risk of that node
crashing losing this state and then
everything is going to be useless
because then we've lost pretty much a
significant chunk of our stream
processing information and this kind of
represents that whole concept of having
like a wide dependency the state on one
local node might represent uh messages
that were partially processed by other
noes and then we would have to go ahead
and reprocess every single message ever
so it's important that um we're able to
kind of go ahead and checkpoint all of
the local state on each node
occasionally so that we know in the
event of a crash we can go ahead and
pull up a new node and have it running
the same thing as that crashed node so
every single time that we have a
checkpoint basically the data uh
consisting of the local state on all of
the nodes is going to be sent to some
high availability persistent distributed
storage like hdfs or S3 and I'll talk
about how checkpointing Works in a
little bit more because that's kind of
interesting to see how it
goes so just before I do talk about
checkpointing let's actually talk about
the architecture of Flink so typically
Flink does the following we have this
kind of single job manager node in the
cluster which goes ahead and takes some
Flint code and establishes this data
flow graph which we can see on the right
here so even though originally the data
flow graph is basically just saying take
some messages from the stream go ahead
and do something called keyby so you're
basically telling um flank how to go
ahead and partition those messages and
then after that send them to a sync
which is basically you know maybe let's
put them in another Stream So the job
manager would go ahead and see something
like this and say okay well I know that
I have a couple of partitions of that
incoming stream so I have to partition
those to a couple of consumer nodes then
after that based on this whole Key by
function we know that all nodes with the
same or all messages rather with the
same key are going to the same node so
that uh you know that's basically just
how partitioning works you want to be
handling the same messages or or similar
messages so that the state is most
relevant so then basically the single
job manager node is going to go ahead
and map out this entire data flow
execution so that it can be parallelized
amongst all the nodes in the cluster and
it'll then go ahead and tell each node
in the cluster known as a task node what
to do um in addition to just telling the
task nodes what to do though the single
job manager node is also responsible for
uh you know sending and receiving
heartbeats from those task manager nodes
and also sending and receiving um
checkpoint data to all of these task
manager nodes and storing the metadata
regarding you know which is the most
recent checkpoint where can we find it
in our distributed storage um now you
might say to yourself okay well
obviously the single job manager node is
going to be a single source of failure
and you would be correct so there's
something similar to Hadoop if you
remember this uh called high
availability mode where basically any
configuration that the single job
manager node would have been storing
just goes instead to an external
coordination service something like
zookeeper or etcd and then you know
because that uses consensus we know that
it's reliable and then we can always
have a backup or a standby job manager
node that in the event the single job
manager node goes down the backup just
goes ahead and reads from zookeeper and
then takes over its
functionality okay so just as a quick
kind of recall slide uh let's remember
log based message Brokers because this
is more or less um what flank is you
know very kind of biased that you should
be pulling your messages from as opposed
to an in-memory non-persistent one and
we'll see why in a second but just as a
um you know to remind you guys log based
message Brokers are just any type of
distributed message CU that um are going
to be partitioned over many nodes and we
have them on dis which means that
messages can be replayed they're not
instantly going to be deleted unless we
need to compact the queue to save space
at some point down the line and
basically what they do is because these
messages are persistent they will
actually have one consumer reading from
each partition and they will keep track
of the offset that the consumer has last
read and this way we can ensure that
every message is going to be processed
at least once because you know if a
consumer were to go down we can say oh
well you know I see that was it offset 4
so if we have another node coming back
to eventually read from this partition
of the queue we should start from off
set 4 and process all messages after
that so keep in mind um this you know
something like this is like Kafka which
is um another Apache project where um
it's another log based message broker
and that's kind of what Flink generally
wants you to use you have a bunch of
ingestion options but uh it works very
well with Kafka and we'll see
why okay so this kind of all ties in
back to checkpointing so just to remind
you checkpointing is basically where we
are going ahead Gathering the local
state amongst every single node in the
cluster and we're going to go ahead and
store that to some sort of distributed
file system or maybe an object store
like S3 so basically here's what happens
the job manager does the following every
once in a while it will send something
known as a checkpoint barrier to all the
nodes in the cluster and the checkpoint
barrier is basically going to be
processed in the same way that any
message might be normally so what that
means is that you know once that
checkpoint barrier is in the system it's
going to to stay in the proper order
right it's not going to like jump the
gun on other messages it's not going to
fall behind it's going to be processed
in order in the same way that you know a
message from a log based message broker
might be so here's what this eventually
does is that basically eventually that
checkpoint barrier is going to be
delivered to all of the nodes in the
cluster because it's kind of being sent
there and that's the entire point of the
job manager and once it does get
delivered there the checkpoint barrier
is going to do the following it's going
to say to any node the cluster okay give
me your local state and also keep track
of the last offset of the message that
you've kind of processed so now the job
manager is going to be getting back from
all of those nodes in the cluster a the
last message that it's consumed from uh
the message broker and B uh its local
state and it's going to persist both of
those things to that distributed file
system and this is kind of what's going
to be comprising of our checkpoint so
basically now if a node crashes we can
restore all these nodes to their
previous state from the checkpoint and
also start processing messages again
from those actual corresponding offsets
we would do this for all of these nodes
so that way we can make sure that every
message is going to be processed and
even if um the checkpoint didn't
encapsulate every single change that had
ever been seen by virtue of going back
to the corresponding offset for that
checkpoint we can reconstruct the state
it's almost like using um a right ahead
log plus checkpoint it's very similar so
the issue here is that it may result in
certain messages being processed more
than once there are a couple ways of
dealing with this one of which is just
using some sort of item potent operation
maybe you have a database that um tells
you which kind of message IDs it's
already seen and that way you can stop
any external services from you know say
you have an email client tied into your
stream uh you know stop a duplicate
email from being sent another option
which is slower but does technically
work is you using two-phase commit so
you do have some options there to ensure
exactly once message semantics but
generally speaking just as kind of a
base thing messages are potentially able
to be processed more than once um
additionally it's important to note that
snapshots are actually created in the
background this is completely
asynchronous so creating them doesn't
actually stop messages from being
processed and they are considered to be
successful by that job manager once it
receives um a success message from all
the nodes reporting that they were able
to go ahead and check check point their
state okay another quick aside that I
want to make is actually changing the
cluster size in flank because we know we
have all these nodes with their local
state and what happens if we either
remove a node from the cluster or add a
new one well we want to basically
rebalance that local state but in the
same way that partitioning has worked
pretty much throughout the entirety of
you know this series and me talking
about it you obviously want to move the
minimum amount of key value pairs over
the network it's kind of important to
use something like consistent hashing
here but basically in order to do this
what Flink does is instead of storing
each checkpoint as um just one object
representing the state of every single
node in the cluster it breaks down each
uh each node State into basically just a
list of key value Pairs and that way
it's really easy to go ahead and
repartition them if need be where you
can basically load in um part of that
checkpoint and that way a new node is
going to be able to get its own
partition
of I guess existing state and then you
can start reprocessing messages from
there okay in conclusion um unlike spark
streaming where basically using micro
batches Flink is a real-time stateful
stream processing engine it's able to
make sure to use basically Shandy
Lamport checkpointing in order to go
ahead and ensure that um you're not
going to be losing State and in doing so
generally speaking this should be
deterministic processing obviously if
you're using non-deterministic methods
in order to create computations like
time then you're going to have a problem
um but that being said Flink is a super
useful stream processing engine that
does a lot for you it's kind of got that
similar philosophy to spark where
basically you go ahead and write very
little code and on the back end or
behind the scenes it goes ahead and does
all that parallelization for you so you
don't have to worry about any race
conditions or even partitioning for that
matter Flink just does it all under the
hood so as a result this is super useful
and it is used in a ton of companies in
order to process Big Data okay have a
good one guys and I'll see you in the
next one